c'est ce qu'on appelle une visite qui
dérange le colonel kadhafi va arriver
dans quelques minutes en france pour une
longue visite de cinq jours
depuis plusieurs jours la venue du
dictateur libyen ce site un flot de
critiques virulentes qui s'étend
maintenant au sein même du gouvernement
la secrétaire d'état aux droits de
l'homme rama yade a émis des réserves
très vives
alors que kadhafi vient encore de
justifier le terrorisme
nora boubetra le drapeau libyen flotte
sur paris et pendant qu'on peaufine les
derniers détails de ce voyage
controversé
la polémique ne cesse d'enfler après un
long silence le quai d'orsay a décidé de
réagir aux voyages du colonel kadhafi
dans la presse ce matin la secrétaire
d'état chargée des droits de l'homme ne
mâche pas ses mots
rama yade n'est pas contre cette visite
mais elle trouve indécent qu'elle
coïncide avec la journée internationale
des droits de l'homme le choix de cette
date est un symbole fort scandaleusement
fort dit elle je suis cet internat au
drague c'est pas moi qui ai créé ce
poste là je suis obligé d'en de
l'assumer et est de prendre des
positions équilibré absolument pas
extrémiste mais équilibré puisque je le
répète je ne suis pas contre le fait
qu'il vienne mais qui viennent ce jour
là c'est un peu difficile à accepter et
qu'en plus il ne pilonne il ne donne pas
l'impression de donner des gages
vis-à-vis des ogm dans son pays c'est ça
qui explique ma mamma position ce matin
bernard kouchner estime que rama yade
est dans son rôle mais lui le ministre
des affaires étrangères préfère plaider
pour le pragmatisme c'est le fait que le
monde évolue qu'un homme kadhafi a
changé du terrorisme qu'il condamnait à
la coopération contre le terrorisme
le fait que l'ouverture se fasse
encourage c'est une diplomatie de
l'ouverture que nous pratiquons une
opposition unanime pour une fois
condamne ce qu'elle appelle la
diplomatie du portefeuille
voilà du côté de l'ump on dit une seule
chose carnet de chèques carnet de
chèques carnet de chèques
il suffit qu'il y ait du pétrole ou du
gaz dans une de ces dictatures là
pour que aussitôt on s'abaisse on tire
le chapeau et on déploie le tapis rouge
avec la visite du colonel kadhafi la
france espère bien il est vrai vendre
ses premiers rafale est signée pour
trois milliards de contrats